so before we get started I like to know
who's in the crowd how many in here are
working in angular
okay how about react Wow
so I've spoken at so many conferences
and I have never seen react outnumber
angular like that that was I was
probably 60 or 70 percent of the room
how about anybody an ember not a one
that's pretty common it's very calm
anybody in backbone
yeah the you back bone people stick
together way to go yes doesn't surprise
me either
okay okay so before we get started I'd
love to know this you can just call it
out what do you feel like is the biggest
pain point for you as a JavaScript
developer today keeping up with
frameworks yes that that is my life
that's why I'm like I'm sorry honey
I will come to bed late tonight somebody
invented something again so I hope it's
good
what else silent failure yes yes oh so
that reminds me of back when I was doing
jQuery it was okay yes some Dom selector
didn't work out great let me begin
figuring this out yeah failing slowly is
really frustrating let me check let's
see we're right at 11 so when do we
formally get started do I get some kind
of a signal or are we already rolling
I'm not sure oh we're rolling hi
everybody
wonderful good morning so I'm Cory house
and this is the JavaScript starter kit
manifesto I am a software architect at
Cox automotive in Kansas City actually
worked for a small company called VIN
solutions that is owned by Autotrader
which is owned by Cox Automotive it's
America we keep acquiring and acquiring
it's yeah I'm also an author at
Pluralsight have a number of courses out
there on clean code on software
architecture on react
my latest courses about building job
development environments I'm an
independent consultant and also I speak
all over the world at conferences and
user groups like this consulting at
businesses as well so if you're
interested reach out to me but enough
about me let's talk about your problems
this this is life for us as JavaScript
developers it is about fatigue
I feel fatigue I imagine that you often
do too and I've been thinking a lot
about this problem that's really
precisely what this talk is about and
and what I want to fix because when it
comes down to it I think what is the
solution to fatigue well one obvious
solution is just to ignore it if you're
feeling overwhelmed by all the
innovation just pretend it's not there
just keep writing vanilla JavaScript see
how that works out for you probably not
well you'll be reinventing the wheel in
so many ways so I feel like this this
isn't a practical solution and I think
if you're in this room you're not
interested in this solution anyway so
option number two is this nobody in this
room has really chosen this solution
that's why I asked at the beginning I
said so who here is working in ember and
not a single oh wait we got an ember
developer in the back
hello ember developer this talk may not
be very useful for you because if you
are working in ember it has so many
opinions on everything a lot of the
things I'm talking about are baked in
and if you don't like them tough luck go
elsewhere that's their opinion so for
most people in this room you're in this
third spot here where I believe that you
need to get together with your team and
create a starter kit that is what I
believe is the solution for the vast
majority of JavaScript developers out
there it's one that we've done so so
we're going to dive in to that idea now
before we started recording here we were
talking about you know the first world
problems of being a JavaScript developer
and all of the pain of oh I just can't
keep up with all these awesome free
libraries yeah light life is very hard
for me people keep giving me all this
free stuff and I can't keep up but this
reminds me a lot of here's a pro tip for
you if you were at a family reunion do
not complain about how your phone keeps
ringing with recruiters wanting to offer
you these awesome jobs your family will
hate you I remember mentioning this just
off the cuff and some thinking people
really looked at me like I had two heads
that happens people call you and ask you
to interview yes in software development
it is fairly common so us complaining
about fatigue and JavaScript is really
us complaining about all the awesomeness
that we could potentially be using to
make our lives better and this is really
our our key pain point is too many
decisions how many well I'm going to
just stand in silence to emphasize this
is our problem today this is gonna keep
going for a while so maybe I won't stand
in silence but what you're going to see
here these are 40 decisions 40 decisions
that if you are doing a file new project
to work in JavaScript you have to decide
all of this this is overwhelming and by
the way this is also why so many people
working in JavaScript today aren't doing
much of what you see up here how many in
here are doing automated testing
consistently in JavaScript less than
half the room less than half the room
and we are at a dedicated JavaScript
conference so I would expect we are a
lot of the alphas in JavaScript and even
us less than half are doing so I believe
it's because we are overwhelmed with the
number of decisions that we have to make
even in that little narrow space so my
question is this if you are feeling
overwhelmed what is the solution to that
overwhelm and my argument is that your
team needs a JavaScript starter kit this
is the way that I think about it while I
am fatigued I'm going to continue
enhancing my team's JavaScript starter
kit and that's precisely what we've done
is started off my team works in react
and in react since it's just a library
it lacks opinions on all sorts of things
bundling and minification and linting
and automated builds and transpiling and
the list goes on and on so one very very
valuable thing you can do is at one time
get together and make those decisions so
that it's not overwhelming for people
getting started later so let's talk for
a second why is this idea of a
JavaScript starter kit so critical well
first it codifies a bunch of decisions
that you're going to have to make
every time you're starting a new project
it codifies the decisions that you've
made the best practices that you want to
follow on your team any of the lessons
that you've learned along the way it
also encourages consistency it
encourages every new project that you
create should look and feel a lot like
the previous one that you made this
helps you avoid forgetting all sorts of
important details see that slide that
had 40 plus decisions on it I bet you
couldn't have listed all of those if you
and I were talking despite the fact that
at one point of the other you were
having to make all of those it's easy
for that stuff to hit the floor so doing
so having this starter kit helps
increase the quality of your project
because it makes doing the right thing
the easy thing that's really important
if you can make the right thing the easy
thing then it's a lot more likely to
happen finally it avoids repeating work
having to set up all of a boilerplate
every time we do something new is just
work that doesn't add a lot of value so
let's quickly get into truly building
the app so this is my tank today's list
of best practices is just too long for
any one of us to hold in our head it is
not practical so what we need is a
starter kit that does that work for you
now so far I've been saying the word
starter kit but I should clarify there's
all sorts of synonyms for this you'll
hear people say JavaScript development
environment boilerplate seed starter
project scaffold generator etc so when
you were googling around looking for
existing ideas these are the sorts of
terms that you can put into Google and
say oh I'm an angular developer angular
boilerplate angular starter project
angular scaffold and you can look at all
sorts of examples of how other people
have solved it as inspiration for your
team's solution so I should clarify here
who is this talk for and who isn't it
for well backing up for a second it
seems pretty much JavaScript is
swallowing the world and Jeff Atwood
quite a while back said that any app
that could be written in JavaScript will
be written in JavaScript and that
sounded pretty silly at the time but now
we're living in an era
we're in p.m. which is effectively
JavaScript's package manager' is the
world's largest package manager over
300,000 packages out there it's crazy
and I believe that this conversation
about having a starter kit applies to
everybody whether you're working for the
web whether you're writing JavaScript on
the server whether you're doing mobile
and native script react native PhoneGap
or if you're writing desktop apps and
something like electron all of these
require a lot of the same decisions I
still have to decide whether I want to
bundle and transpile how I want to do
automated deployments how I want to lint
my code and the list goes on and on so
having a starter kit for all these
places is useful so this talk is
effectively I think for any JavaScript
developer so who isn't it for well it's
probably not for the guy in the back
that's doing ember hi guy in the back
he's laughing it's like why did I come
here I could have went to Elijah manners
talk it looked awesome by the way thank
you all for coming because that's where
I'd like to be his talk looks awesome
so ember is great because ember has all
these opinions baked in and Ember you
don't have to decide how to do testing
you don't have to decide how to do a CLI
and you don't have to decide where to
put your files or what to name all of
that is just baked in because you chose
Ember
now given the thing is a lot of people
don't like embers opinions and you don't
really have a choice in the matter you
have to take them and I think that's
precisely why in this room of people
only one person has chose an ember
because people look at it and go yeah it
just doesn't quite fit me and this is
precisely why a starter kit is so
powerful because you and your team given
your own opinions your own experiences
can build a starter kit that works best
for you and and this concept of starter
kit is going to apply more to you as you
sit on the left hand side of this screen
for instance if you're working in
reacting node there's not a whole lot of
opinion there it's hey here's some
tooling get started go pull other things
off the shelf and get it done if you're
working an ember on the other hand
embers like a religion you got to accept
it all or you're not going to fit in so
this is a gamut of opinion I also find
it very interesting that angular has
become very very popular as a framework
that is
sitting somewhere in the middle here
it's not super super opinionated but it
does have more opinion with react than
react does for instance which makes it
for some people feel more approachable
of course another decision you have to
make is whether to go pull down someone
else's boilerplate or rather to build
your own of course if you use someone
else's boilerplate you can save time you
you know that is proven because other
people have put it to use and it's often
very full-featured but if you build your
own this is huge you have freedom you
have freedom to make it yours to build
it in a way that fits your team best to
put only the features in that you care
about it makes it the perfect fit for
your team and this helps avoid all the
unnecessary complexity that's often in
existing solutions that you see
elsewhere and this means that this is
rather important you actually understand
it if you go pull down my boiler plate
which is react slingshot and it's gonna
take you a while to look at it all
because that is me encapsulating about a
year's worth of work so it's a lot of
code to take in you wouldn't expect to
immediate and it but if you build your
own from scratch using other people's as
inspiration your team really does know
it and that makes this last point key it
makes it easy to change so a few years
ago well I shouldn't say a few years ago
about a year ago I read a book called
the checklist manifesto and this really
hit me hard as a developer because as
developers we could really use
checklists and I think as developers we
we tend to move away from them but
imagine this imagine I'm a doctor I have
a patient sitting on the on the bed I
have to run a line into their body I'm
gonna have to make an incision when I'm
going to make that incision it is really
key that I go through a list of steps to
make sure that they don't get an
infection I have to wash my hands
thoroughly put on a cap I have to put a
sterile dressing over a part of their
body there is five different key things
that I need to do if I skip just one of
those steps then someone is very likely
to get an infection now here's what's
interesting if I go ask a doctor what
those five steps are
that doctor can immediately rattle off
that list it's not a problem but in
studies where doctors have been
monitored in actual hospitals what they
found is a portion of the time they miss
it
they miss one of those steps and it's so
easy to understand the same thing
happens to us as developers we know that
we should do automated testing we know
that linting is useful
we know that minification is important
but a lot of us don't because it's just
a step that gets skipped we get busy and
we get focused on completing the task
and there's some very interesting
takeaways from this that that we think
we can remember all the steps but we
just can't it is not practical so these
doctors that were followed they were
told that they needed to implement a
checklist which a lot of doctors are
averse to because they say hey I'm a
professional I shouldn't need a
checklist we as developers feel the same
way but what they found was this once
they had a checklist that they were
following line infection rates fall from
11% to zero zero and this is really
important because when somebody gets an
infection in the ICU they are very very
likely to have other serious
complications and often die this is what
the checklist prevented over a year
period 43 infections 8 deaths over two
million dollars in costs by having a
checklist what if we as software
developers had a checklist that was
helping make sure that we did the right
things that's precisely what we need is
JavaScript developers so those 40 items
up there on that slide you can't
remember them it's too much and don't
let it make you feel like you're not
professional because remember we just
saw doctors know what to do but it's
easy to overlook a step same story with
developers because the starter kit is an
automated living an interactive
checklist that's what makes it so
powerful
ok so let's shift gears for a second I
want to talk about what belongs in your
starter kit there's a long list of
things that I think belong there
we should think about package management
bun
minification source maps transpiling
dynamic HTML generation centralized HTTP
requests a mock API frameworks that you
can code without the actual API being
created yet component libraries of
course so that you can actually build
your app without just plain using
vanilla Jas a development web server so
that you don't have to spin something up
manually linting automated testing
continuous integration an automated
build process again this shouldn't be
something done manually and then in
automated deployment so that it's
repeatable finally I believe that there
should be a working example app there as
part of your application that's a heck
of a list so when we look at that list
right there how many of you in this room
are honestly doing all those things
today as a JavaScript developer ember
guy thank you it's like I yeah it's like
we coordinated this that's that's
awesome so there and this is the thing
there's no good reason that an angular
developer or react developer a backbone
developer they could be doing all of
this and I will tell you as a react
developer my team is doing all of this
but the reason that we're doing all of
this is because we're using a starter
kit that just bakes it all in and by
having that baked in every time we start
a new project we don't have to pay for
any of this it's free and that is really
powerful so I want to go through a
lightening round here for those of you
that are taking notes get your pencils
ready because what I'm going to share is
a lot of opinions very very quickly of
course this talk is really an
encapsulation of a 5 hour course that I
just published on Pluralsight but I'm
trying to give you the really key ideas
and I'm gonna warn you I'm gonna make
strong opinions here and I don't have
time to justify them but afterwards I
would love to talk to everybody and I'd
love to have lunch with some of you um
so you can tell me how much you hate me
for my opinions it'll be fun
yeah we can be friends ok so starting
this is really really important as
JavaScript developers we are burdened by
this paradox of choice I really love
this book so the book paradox of choice
talks about the problem of
when we are presented with so many
options what we tend to do is just say
I'm paralyzed
I'm paralyzed by the options so I'm not
going to move at all here's an example
of this there was a study they showed
okay you go into a grocery store the
grocery store clerk is offering you
grape jelly and strawberry jelly which
one would you like to sample and you
walk up well this is an easy decision I
like grape jelly I'll try this lots of
people came up and tried that later they
had 65 jellies sitting there on the
table and how do you choose when there's
that made people look up and they go I'm
overwhelmed I'm just not even going to
bother I don't know I can't decide
amongst all this and that's precisely
what we're running into today and
JavaScript with people trying to say
well should I use jasmine or mocha or
Jess or Q unit Oh it's overwhelming so
I'm going to share opinions and I
believe this
Dierks Ivor said that strong opinions
are very useful to others because those
who are undecided or ambivalent can just
adopt your stance but those who disagree
can solidify their stance by arguing
against yours isn't that fun so that's
what I'm going to do is help you out
here's my two cents time for the
lightning round let's get rolling step
number one you need to choose an editor
and I would argue this these are the
four best options to choose if you are
trying to do JavaScript development
today in Visual Studio or in NetBeans in
some kind of a large IDE I believe
that's the wrong decision my favorite
editor is webstorm I would highly
recommend it it is not free but I
believe in buying the best tools for the
job if you don't want to pay for
webstorm BS code is a really nice second
place I've been spending a lot of time
there
regardless setup editor config this will
enforce consistency on your team tabs
versus spaces tab spacing size a lot of
other little settings and then everybody
regardless of editor will have these
enforced on their team you need to
choose a package manager this is an easy
decision which package manager should
you use NPM there we go we have agreed
as a team other options out there but I
really JSP M is interesting but honestly
I would just suggest using NPM you need
to pick a development web server well I
think HTTP server is pretty cool because
a turn
strapped to a rocket how awesome is that
that is a great logo but seriously I
would recommend really looking into
browsersync it is super impressive if
you've never seen this before
take a tablet take a bunch of different
phones glue them to the wall hook them
all up to your machine and as you browse
on your machine using browser sync all
of those other devices will be in sync
and you'll see as you click as you
scroll it's all there it's completely
free very very cool
you need a way to quickly share your
work in progress now on my team what we
like to use is local tunnel what local
tunnel does is I just say local tunnel
port 3000 and then immediately it
punches a hole in the firewall lets
people go directly to my dev machine so
they can consume my work-in-progress I
don't have to push it out to a public
server they are seeing my live
development right there very very easy
to get going you need to choose an
automation approach I again think this
is an easy decision I used to be a big
fan of grunt and then I was out there
evangelizing gulp like crazy then I
finally realized you know what
NPM is simpler I don't see any reason to
reach for grunt or gulp anymore I have a
long blog post on this if you just
Google for NPM versus gulp or why I left
gulp for NPM there's the fact is what
NPM does is gets rid of the plug-in
abstraction that exists with gulp and
grunt and once you get rid of that
abstraction which from my experience
just wasn't buying me anything it gets
easier to debug easier to read the docks
and you don't have to wait for these
plugins to show up another decision here
you need to pick a module format oh I'm
sorry you need to pick a transpiler I'm
a big fan of Babel so that is what we
use typescript is very interesting if
you can get your team to use Elm though
huge huge win here's the most amazing
thing about Elm if you haven't heard it
in Elm it is not possible to get a
runtime error blew my mind it is amazing
and it and it is really really helpful
with its compile time error messaging
now nonetheless I choose Babel because
Babel lets me use everything in the
JavaScript ecosystem if I choose
typescript there are some things that I
truly can't use yes lint is one example
yes lint will soon add typescript
support but I don't believe it's quite
here yet
when react first came out I couldn't you
with typescript because the syntax is
conflicted so that's why typically
prefer to just use Babel you need to
choose a module format I think these
days this is a pretty easy decision use
es6 modules if you're in node then of
course go ahead and use your command j s
for now but yes six modules are the
future so if you don't know these others
don't bother learning them they are now
the past you need to pick a bundler I
also think that this is a very easy
decision if you are building a web
application use webpack it's awesome and
it is getting much much better every day
the docks are finally not awful for web
back to the docks are really very very
good and they're very soon to be
production grade not quite there yet
my one exception is if you were writing
a library instead of a web application
roll up is quite slick right now no I
think soon web pack 2 may be a really
good choice for libraries as well but
for now roll ups tree shaking abilities
are quite slick you need to pick a
linter again very very easy decision
just use es lint I cannot think of a
single reason to reach for J s hint or
jslint if anybody has one come see me
afterward and that wasn't an offer to
fight or anything I just want to have
conversation I should clarify ok this
one's huge if you're going to do
automated testing this is why people
don't do automated testing that's why
less than half of this room at November
is doing automated testing cuz you look
at this list and go volt I don't know I
gotta choose a framework and on
assertion library what helpers where
should I put my tests what should I name
them that's overwhelming but I like to
think of it like this it's like choosing
a gym have you ever stood up by the guy
that goes yeah I need to choose a gym I
was shopping over here I was trying to
decide what shoes I should wear and I
don't have the right clothes and then
should I do aerobics or weights no no no
no just go to the gym do something at
the gym for a half hour and you will be
better off and sitting and vacillating
on the decisions so when we talk about
automated testing the important part is
showing up that's key so the right
answer when you're trying to choose a
JavaScript framework is any of these
just pick one you'll be just fine
some are a little bit better than others
I have my preferences I typically use
mocha these days although just has
really become quite impressive as well
but the wrong answer is to be this guy
well just keep hoping and praying maybe
it'll work out and the reason that guy
does that is he's overwhelmed with all
the options so as a team just pick it
and go you need a continuous integration
server so many out here and a my take is
if you're hosting on github Travis is
the easiest way to get going so just use
Travis if there's some reason that you
need Windows support use that bayar
we're actually using at Bayer and Travis
because my team half of us are on Macs
half of us are on PCs so we need to know
that our build works on both systems so
we just have to CI servers hey they're
free no big downside you need to choose
how to make HTTP calls all sorts of
interesting ways out there to do it you
probably shouldn't be reaching for plain
old XML HTTP requests anymore
look at some of these over on the right
I'm a big fan of Axios I hope I'm saying
that right
nobody's correcting me we're gonna go
with it yeah
super agents also are really useful
fetch is the new standard which is worth
considering but there are some
limitations to it it's not as
full-featured is using something like
super agent or Axios you need to choose
an HTTP mocking approach I like to use
JSON server I just posted a blog post a
few days ago if you go out on medium
look for Corey house on medium you'll
find the blog post on it and there's an
example github repository I am super
excited about this because I will tell
you this we are right now building an
application that's huge this is the very
core of our system and the API team is
not gonna have time to even get started
on it for a couple months but we are
nearly done with user interface and when
you use the interface
it looks real because we are generating
realistic data we say generate a
realistic username realistic password
realistic looking vehicles realistic
even pictures I can say hey here's a
mock API that comes out and generates a
URL to some CD in that gives me an image
of a certain size so that it can have
placeholders when I add and delete it is
writing to it just a static JSON file
instead of a real DB so this is what's
crazy we live in a world now where as
JavaScript developers for free you can
say alright if I'll stand up a mock API
that completely simulates a real one
even down to all the
read create read update delete story so
it is completely interactive when the
API is ready all we will do is point at
the real one instead so cool I also
believe you need a demo application and
then this is why there's going to be
people on your team that still want to
default to the old mode of all just slap
some code in a script tag a demo app
shows everybody how you work as a team
and when you were trying to do this
examples really help then people know ok
here's how we name our files here's the
recommended directory structure here's
where we put our reducers here's where
we put our plain utility methods here's
how we structure our components the list
goes on and on but examples speak
volumes to people it's like that rule of
a picture's worth a thousand words
that's exactly what a demo app does for
people you also finally need an
automated deployment step and this is
our structure we say NPM start that
starts up the application it runs our
tests it runs our linting it doesn't
spins up a development web server and
then we see our app sitting there every
time that we hit save our changes are
hot reloaded in the browser so we see
those immediately once we're happy with
our dev we go ahead and say npm run
build that generates a production build
rights to a dist folder opens up a web
servers that we can see the minified
application running in our browser now
we can see okay yes it's truly ready for
production let's type in PM run deploy
it's an automated deployment out to our
production environment so it's a nice
three-step process there's no no
opportunity there for human mistakes
along the way because it's automated now
because of time I'm not going to go
through a demo of our starter kit but
the starter kit that I'm using is called
react slingshot it's out there it's
open-source you can Google for it
this is the funny thing though there are
so many starter kits it's hilarious and
this this is where people can start to
feel overwhelmed by the number of
starter kits starter kits were created
to help people feel less fatigued but
now people just feel fatigued because
there's so many a starter kits to choose
from if you're a react developer Google
for Andrew farmer Andrew farmer has
created
a database of react starter kits there
are over a hundred of them over a
hundred mine which has over five
thousand stars is number six on the list
in popularity there are five with a lot
more so what you realize is wow there's
a lot of demand for this and what I
would suggest doing don't go use one as
is look at a number of different ones
and say I like this I like this I like
this okay team let's take these good
ideas and put them together into our own
so in closing I have a challenge to you
my challenge is very very simple I want
you to send the meeting invitation to
your team I think that a single meeting
could be really helpful to you and these
are three questions that I'd suggest
that you answer would we benefit from
having a starter kit what are our pain
points today
the very first gentleman when I said
what are your pain points in JavaScript
said feeling overwhelmed with all of the
churn in JavaScript all of the decisions
that we have to make and then room we
know that that's the case if that's your
pain point then a starter kit can
resolve that core pain point and you
have to ask yourself would we benefit
from having a demo app so when new
people join our team we say here's an
example of how we write code this is how
we work in JavaScript so to wrap up
I have tried here to give you the
encapsulated version of a five hour and
17 minute course on Pluralsight that I
just launched last week this is a topic
that's really important to me though
because what I see is a lot of
developers struggling with the pain and
the fatigue from all of these decisions
so I'd really encourage you to set up
that meeting make that first step and
reduce the fatigue that your team is
feeling today it really has helped us I
will tell you when we start now going in
and starting with a starter kit people
again and again come in and go wow you
know what react is really quite easy to
get started on I just type in p.m. start
and I start creating components and I go
well yeah it feels that way because you
didn't have to pay down all the pain
that our teams put in four months
months to make it luxurious because
trust me if you just go grab the library
it's not gonna feel this way I am how
score on Twitter I'd love to hear
feedback I also have a request for you
all I have some free trials for
Pluralsight 30-day trial sitting in my
bag if you come up here and tell me one
thing to change about the talk I'll give
you a free trial but you got to be me
and say something I could have done
better because I'm trying to improve
along the way we are tagged up against
lunch here so I'm cool with standing up
here and visiting for a few I'd love
feedback and then if some of you want to
have lunch just let me know and I'd love
to go over there and talk more
JavaScript with everybody that's what I
have thank you for listening
[Applause]